joining me today is a Canadian
businessman lawyer Member of Parliament
and the founder and head of the People's
Party of Canada
Maxine Bern a welcome to the Reuben
report thanks for the invitation
dave am very happy to be with you I am
glad you're here I am pretty sure how
many people are there in Canada roughly
37 median p37 so I've gotten about 36
million emails the show or on Twitter I
mean everybody in Canada seems to want
us to do this sit-down so so I'll do my
best so we shall see what there's many
reasons that I'm looking forward to this
chat and originally we're gonna do this
on skype and then you were gracious
enough to say let's say let's do this in
person the fact that somebody in Canada
is spreading the ideas of Liberty and of
the individual and limited government
all of those things is incredibly
inspiring to me and it's more of what we
need down here too but let's just start
first with a little bit of your
biography for people that don't know
anything about you yes I'm a lawyer I
did also a course in businesses before
and I work in the private sector in
Montreal Quebec in the financial sector
I was VP of Financial Institutions and
after that I work with the module
economic Institute that's a free-market
think tanks like maybe the Mises
Institute and like that I was VP over
there and in 2005 I had a meeting with
Stephen Apple at that time it was the
leader of the Opposition before the
election in 2006 and so it was looking
for some ideas to be able to have some
seats in Quebec as you know Quebec is
the francophone part of the country and
so we had a good chat together and I
told him you know there's two important
things that you must say to Quebecers if
you want to win first you must respect
the Constitution because in Quebec if
you remember we had a to referendum and
we we still have a separatist political
party at the parental level so I told
him you know respect the Canada
and constitution don't interfere in
province or jurisdiction and everything
will be okay and also lower taxes income
tax to Quebecers and all Canadians and
at the end that was I think a good
proposal for Quebec but also for all
across the country and he decided to put
that in his platform and he asked me to
run with him in 2006 so I decided to run
and my riding my district it is in both
near Quebec City it's after all
afterburn riding and I went there
because my dad was an MP under Bryan
Maroni for 13 years and so when I came
in both in 2006 to run the director of
my campaign told me Maxime we have a
problem with you because I was working
in Montreal I was not in the writing he
said you have a name my dad was very
well known but you don't have a first
name
so my goal at the end of the campaign
people must know you so I did a good
campaign and at the end I won and also
Stephen Harper we formed the government
in 2006 a minority government 2008 a
minority government and I was industry
minister at that time I did a big
deregulation in Telecom and that's why
people at that time they they call me
the Albertan from Quebec because in
Alberta there are very free markets and
Quebec at the pine-sol level we have a
big fat and socialist government so and
ideally great the telecom industry it
was a big success
and after that Primus authorized me to
be the Foreign Affair and I was a fun
affair for a year and I resigned and I
came back in the cabinet in 2010 and I
was Minister for small business and
after that Minister for State for
agriculture and so we had a majority
government in 2000 and
eleven and so we did some reform and
after that in 2015 and tweedle when in
power and I'm still a member of
parliament and upper resigning as the
leader of the party and the fun is
coming right now because I decided to
run for the leadership yeah and I create
after that I didn't win with forty-nine
percent of the votes and I was the most
people tallien candidate and I had a
very strong platform about individual
freedom personal responsibility actually
the four teams of our platform was
individual freedom personal
responsibility respect and fairness and
all our policies were based on these
principles that was very successful at
49 percent and you know I was the only
one to say we must abolish corporate
welfare one good percent we must also
cut foreign aid and and do a lot of
changes like that on the economy and
also on the immigration I had a strong
platform so I didn't win I tried to walk
with the new leader and Russia try to I
wanted the leadership of the
Conservative Party of Canada to add up
some of our reforms because that was
very popular and a year later he told me
that they don't want me anymore they
won't take any of all of the ideas that
I put forward and also I did a couple of
tweets that didn't like and so I
resigned from the party and in September
I decided to create the People's Party
of Canada yeah all right so your basic
political pedigree yeah
is there an inherent sort of oddity of a
libertarian trying to go into government
where most people that go into
government want to grow government they
believe that if only their policies were
instituted they could have a better
government that could do more and so on
versus a libertarian comes in you cut
regulation you wanted to cut some
programs etc etc it's almost like you're
trying to shrink the thing that's also
your job now you've had real jobs also
so I suspect you could look at it
perhaps a little bit differently yeah
because you know was in the private
sector before and I know that too much
government it is not bringing prosperity
and kind of Austrian economies also like
Mises and all you know my my prefer
website is mrs. org so I'm on the
economy I can call you can call me a
libertarian but I'm not a really Bert
Ryan because really Burton will ask for
open borders or no more regulations or
legislation on drugs and so I don't
believe in that I think we must have a
state that will have some regulation
basic regulations so how do you figure
out where that line is that's been one
of the ends that I talk about with a lot
of different guests and that sort of
seems to be a little bit of a difference
between people who consider themselves
classical liberals and libertarians
where there's a little more say hand of
the state on the classical liberal side
libertarians it's hard to know where
where the end is you know we are we just
in Mad Max so for me it's it's all about
the economy that's the most important
and yes you know our social policies
must be for more freedom and personal
responsibility and I tried to make a big
difference with the state and the
economy like we did in the past with the
states and religious you know so that's
always important to have this difference
and on the economy it's easy to be a
libertarian and Apple it's easier to be
a libertarian and a politician because
you know it's all special interest group
that are coming to you and they want a
privilege or or or more more subsidies
or things like that so I'm making the
line when I'm saying you know I want me
what I want I want to work for all
Canadians and not for a special interest
group and when I don't know a special
interest group is coming to us and they
just want to promote their privilege or
to keep their privilege that would be
easy for me to say no I won't do that
the best example was the the cartel that
we have in Canada in in Supply
Management that's a socialist system
that Pierre Elliot Trudeau put forward
45 years ago where milk poultry and eggs
the producers are fixing the price and
fixing the production for the Canadian
market they cannot export so Canadians
are paying twice the price for meal
poultry and eggs if you compare that
with the price that you're paying here
in the US so these cartel is very
powerful and when they came to me and
they wanted to keep their privilege I
say no you know will abolish that will
have a transition period you'll be able
to export I believe in a real free
market its if a free market is good for
every industry must be good also for
these people so what's the
counter-argument on that though if
Trudeau now yeah not the old Trudeau but
if our courage we get or your country
yeah was giving the counter-argument on
why you wouldn't free that up yeah that
just because he doesn't believe in free
market economics but it's because it is
a powerful lobby and also they want to
keep seats also and they're very
powerful in rural areas in the country
and and so for their powerful second is
buying in their arguments that you know
if we have mail from the US or eggs from
the US that won't be the same quality
and we need to stop that for being sure
that we can control the quality of our
products and so that's another argument
but for me you know when you have a
legislation everybody must respect that
so if you want to export to Canada your
eggs or your poultry or your milk you
must follow the Canadian legislation and
regulation that's that's a new deal and
but it's it's it's the powerful they are
very powerful so they the thinking is
they want to keep not only to do but
also also my former party the
Conservative Party of Canada the NDP
also they they are too afraid to to just
just listen to Canadians they think that
all we have a good system and eating
that carrion
the thing that Canadians don't
understand that system they think that
Canadian don't understand that they're
paying twice the price so the more I
speak about that the more popular it is
and that was very important in my
campaign for the leadership and it is
also part of our platform right now so
answering your questions why do you want
to keep that cartel I think it's only
for political reason so is the idea of
Liberty and personal responsibility and
some of the other things that you're
running on are these oddly new in Canada
and I say that because when when you
started coming on my radar about a year
ago I saw people started tweeting about
you there were a lot of people saying
something to the effect of wow if a
libertarian is needed in Canada then
something really must be wrong there as
if there was no need for it for a long
time but maybe something unique is
happening now
yeah people are ready for the new ideas
and I think people are fed up with
traditional politicians that are saying
something at the end they oppose it the
other day a politician that tried to
please the special interest group so
what I'm doing you know I'm doing
politics differently and you know
there's no political correctness for our
party I'm saying what I what must be
said for better policies in this country
in Canada sorry
and so the I think people are ready and
and what's happening actually right now
you know it's good to have the right
ideas but it's good it's better to have
the right ideas at the right time and I
think the timing is very good for us for
me because we have a government in
Ottawa right now the Trudeau government
that are spending a lot of money huge
deficit people they don't see and we
don't know when they will balance the
budget it must be around 20 2014 oh is
that the deficit of today all the taxes
of tomorrow so a huge deficit huge taxes
in Ottawa and the economy is so so right
now in Canada so people are looking for
a kind of alternative and and I think
the timing is good for me because
in a poll is 57% of Canadians said
Ameobi a month ago that they're ready to
vote for a new party so we are very new
party four months a month old and
they're ready to vote for a new party
and not voting for the traditional
parties something is happening I think
the big government in Ottawa
every time putting a lot of regulations
and a lot of subsidies to businesses you
know the government bailout the GM a
couple of years ago more than 2.5
billion dollars and GM said two months
ago that they will leave Canada yeah so
it's a waste of money we're giving a lot
of money to big businesses and all the
other politicians are saying it's okay
we must tell business what I'm saying
yes we must help businesses but every
businesses having a fair policy that is
to lower taxes to every businesses and
not giving subsidies and picking winner
and loser so I think people are ready
for a change they're seeing what's
happening in our country and they know
that we're not going in the right
direction right now so let's talk a
little bit about regulation yeah because
I think a lot of people think especially
if they're on the Left right now they
think if you say I'm cutting regulation
well first they go to environmental
regulation yeah I think that's what they
think first so I do want to ask you
about that but also they think if you're
just talking about it purely in a
business level but that means that
capitalism will then run amok cuz you
know that all of these businesses will
then start dumping in the rivers and
doing shady deals with each other and
competition will be crushed in all of
those things so you want to do business
or environment first on the regulation
front yeah I think let's do let's do
business person yeah let's do business
first you know business must answer the
needs of their consumers so a consumers
are asking for better products and for
products that will respect the
environment that's why they are asking
for electric cars and so you don't
always need regulation to force that the
free markets
the wish of the people will force
businesses to adopt their practice in
the right way and so when you have when
you have a real free market and when you
you have competition it's always good at
the end for the consumers you'll have a
better products and you'll have lower
prices but at the same thing the way at
the same time the way that they are
producing their products will change
right now you know people the best and
some people are telling me you know we
must have you know cooperate or social
cooperated we call that corporate social
corporate wealth no no corporate social
identity a corporation must be socially
well oh they have like a social
awareness and I said you know not really
because a corporation first must make
profits if they don't make any profit
they won't be able to do anything so if
they're profitable it's because you
wants their consumers wants their goods
and hundred products so that's the first
goal of our cooperation to make products
and and I think that you need regulation
but what we're doing right now every
time that something happened we put a
new regulation but they must be
responsible of their actions
corporations and individuals so that
that's important for me and I think
Canadian understand that yeah what about
on the environmental side I think yeah
this is the big one I think he's been
for people who can understand free
market I think you just can't leave this
environmental issues up to to private
companies yeah you know you can sue a
corporation if they don't respect the
regulations actually you know clean
water it's very important but you know
when you have facilities that are owned
by the government or by the
municipalities everything must be public
if they are doing person and things like
that
if the water is clean or not when it's
not public you cannot you cannot sue
them if they don't if they don't respect
the regulation so I remembered
Margaret Thatcher in Europe the way to
clean water over there was to have a
regulation saying every test that you're
doing and that was done by
municipalities public entity must be
public and you will be responsible to be
sure that you respect the regulation she
just put a regression on that every test
was public and five years later the
water was cleaner that it was before
because they didn't want to be sued they
didn't want to be so so they were
responsible so when you have a real free
market what everything is on the table
and you know the information that's
bring usually a better quality of water
or land and so you have property right
for that and property right it's the
basics of all that but speaking about
environment now the debate in Canada its
climate change yeah so so everybody want
to do something about climate change and
I'm the only party who said you know we
won't do anything environment in Canada
it's a shared jurisdiction with
provinces and the federal government and
I don't believe in the Paris Accord I
don't believe that kinda would be able
to achieve the goals that they put in
the Paris Accord and actually the UN and
the radical environmental in Canada said
the same thing that we don't want to
impose a carbon tax of $20 a ton and he
must impose a carbon tax of at least
$200 a ton if you want to achieve its
target so at $20 a times it will be only
a distortion for the economy and and
hardworking families will pay our prices
so that's why you know I don't believe
in Paris Accord and I think that we must
not impose new regulation on that we
must let provinces and other provincial
government if they want to have a
cap-and-trade like they have here in US
and other kind of a process for that for
us I want to have a program that will
maybe be very strong on clear water
clear hair something that people
understand and having the property
rights that will work and more
information you need more information at
the same time to be sure that people
will understand if
Lake is clear or not yeah so I'm glad
you mention that because it seems to me
that it's about information and being
able to get your messaging across so for
example the Paris Accords which
obviously the United States pulled out
of it seems very easy if you listen to
the media it was very easy we have to be
part of the Paris Accords and then if
you ask anyone what the Paris Accords
are they have no idea if you ask them
loans in a binding is there any you know
is there anyone watching to make sure
any of this happens they have no idea
and the answer is no I just read last
month that despite the despite the u.s.
pulling out of the Accords that right
now the u.s. is meeting most if not or
exceeding all of the standards that be
of course so how much of this is just
about getting your messaging across
because this will shift us a little bit
to talking about the media yeah which
you had an interesting relationship with
yeah you're right about that you know
it's all about virtue signaling for a
politician and but I think can you
didn't understand that they understand
when I'm saying you know the Trudeau
government actually right now they are
appropriate they are saying something to
the population knowing that it won't be
able to achieve that so I prefer to tell
the truth saying you know we won't think
that and we won't do anything to achieve
that and we won't spend 2.3 billion
dollars to send that to African
countries to help them to fight climate
change I think we must help Canadian
first so that's part of our platform but
the other party like the Conservative
Party also they don't want to have a
carbon tax but they want to impose more
regulations on Canadian businesses and
that's not the solution but they try to
please maybe the media but also a
portion of the population and I think
that you know when you explain and
that's what I like in politics you know
I like to explain our policies and why
we we are having the right policies
based on freedom and responsibility and
when you explain that the more you
explain I think the better people
understand it and the more more people
will want to vote for our party so for
me when I'm the only one to speak
against the Paris Accord
they're a huge clientele there and it
won't hurt me it will help me at the end
and um you know my my deal with
Canadians is be true tell what you
believe in and have some debates we'll
debate and that's important for me
so yes the media are playing an
important role but we need to use also
the social media and that's why you know
I'm very pleased to be here to speak to
the American audience and Canadians
audience and just try to have a
conversation with them and you yeah well
what's the state of the media you guys
have a whole different set of problems
there what is going on with the CBC you
just saw everything else in Canada yeah
you know we have the CBC I like how your
whole body language yeah we have the CBC
and the federal government is giving
about 1.3 billion dollars a year to the
state broadcaster the CBC and in French
it's kudzu Canada and I'm the only
politician and it's but it's a very
popular policy that we must cut that
because it is unfair the CBC are
competing with other private broadcaster
for the advertising and also they
receive money from the government so it
is not fair we must cut the CBC and I
what I want I want the CBC to get it a
bit like PBS in the state if they are so
good they will be able to have money
from their viewers but also the CBC they
are editorial board or a little bit I
will be very very kind a little bit left
is yeah so very young yeah yeah it's
worse in French though the radio Canada
in French or more leftist than CBC
sometimes it's is there a reason for
that you know it's like your media here
it's a bit but but the worse thing is it
is funded by the government yes so so if
you're I don't know CNN and you don't
receive any phone by the government and
want to to
be on the left it's your corporate
decision but the CBC must be more
neutral and they're not so that's the
big problem that we have in Canada the
way to fix that it's first of all CBC
must be must receive money from their
viewers first and second the government
must if the government is giving money
to a CBC we must know the what's
happening and maybe the executive of the
CBC must be before the Parliament once a
year to explain their editorial policy
but that being said the media we have
the CBC we have the traditional media
but when you're a real conservative or
right-wing politician you don't have the
same coverage then the Liberals or the
left they're having in in these
traditional media do you think in a
weird way that that's working to your
favor now because at least in the
circles that I can see you seem to be
the hottest Canadian politician despite
the fact and it's maybe it's fueled by
maybe they're not despite maybe because
of the fact that you're the outsider
from the media and people are so fed up
with the media that it's like oh here's
this guy doing it you know yeah it's
circumventing it and also you know when
the media the traditional media are
writing something about us or my party
that it's not true I will call that I
will and I'm very very factual on on
social media and Twitter about it and
you know I don't try to please everybody
or I don't write to please the media
they have to do a job if they're fair
it's okay if they are not fair we'll be
out there and and I will I will argue my
case and that's not all all the
pollution the pollution I'm not doing
that they want to be fine with the media
they don't want to have a fight with the
media and for me I will have a fight
with a journalist if is not doing its
job and I think people appreciate that
so yes when they are doing something not
objective on our policies on my party
that can help
again because you know the credibility
of journalist it is not the same with
people like you on social media people
have another way to find their news and
their little bit more critics towered
the traditional journalist and yes I
agree with you that can help me yeah
that's a politician are you able to
debate some of your political opponents
these days I mean to anyone in Canada
put these kind of talks on television
where you can actually get into the
ideas no usually when I'm on traditional
TV in Canada it's all about you know and
506 minutes yeah I want to get yeah I
mean yeah yeah they want Leon to have it
and they don't give you enough time to
answer the questions and go deeper in
the subject but that's why I use social
media that's why I'm prison in social
media so but you know I need to deal
with that and I think it's going very
well right now
so how does this all linked to just sort
of a state of free speech in Canada
because there does something seem to be
something particularly unique yeah in
Canada which is why I've had so many
Canadian guests and why Canada is
usually our second or third most mute
country obviously there was the Jordan
Peters who didn't was c16 yeah there's
what happened with Lindsay Shepard at
yeah Wilfred Laurier yeah yeah you've
got GAD sat up there who's always
fighting the Battle of free speech is
there something is it is this new what's
happening related to political
correctness in Canada yeah I think first
of all that started 40 years ago in the
university in Canada like in the US but
now what's happening there's some
politician who believe in that and with
that motion m1 which we the bill see 16
now these people that were that we're on
the school couple of years ago 40 years
ago now some of them are politicians and
you have this debate right now and it's
it's good for us that we have Jordan
Peterson and people like that we must
fight I think we must not take for
granted in Canada or freedom of
expression free speech and and we must
fight and I'm doing that as a politician
and you know with that bill c16 that was
crazy bill you know Jordan they want to
force his Jordan to speak with a
transgender not he or she but what was
the word was whatever they want whatever
they want yeah but there's no obligation
you know hey there's no big Asian to
please everybody yeah that what this all
comes down to though that people just
don't understand the fundamental
responsibilities of government in a free
society I mean if we were boiling all
this into one thing yeah that seems to
me to be it yeah you don't want the
government to tell you what to do you
don't want the government to tell you
what to say you know it's the basics of
our democracy and actually you know one
of our candidate Laura lein because
we're we have three by-elections in
Canada at the end of February the 25th
of February and I will have candidates
the People's Party of Canada will have
candidate and one of our candidate local
in in BC Burnaby BC in that riding she
at the Panchala ball fight for gender
against the gender fluidity in BC in the
school it's a provincial jurisdiction
they wanted to teach at school to young
kids that if you're a boy you may not be
a boy and if you're a girl you may not
be a girl and you can choose your sex
the state wants to impose that and to
teach that to young people and locally
ancient no I I don't want that I don't
want the state to tell us what to do in
that must be the responsibility of the
parents you don't have to put that in
the mind of a young boys six or seven or
five years old so but when she decided
to be our candidate all the mainstream
media's over Bernie and I said you know
she has the right to her own opinion and
that's a great debate that they had at
the potential level now she's doing
politics at the federal level but you
know they were tried they were trying to
look at her like you know
maybe a crazy candidate because she she
she has some some opinions and strong
opinions but you know because I believe
in freedom of speech our candidates can
have opinions like that we have
candidates that are pro-choice we have
candidates that are pro-life but just
ain't we're doing the Liberals they
don't want any pro-life candidates so
for me my party must be like the are
Canadian Society so yes I will tolerate
different point of view yeah but people
must be all V on our programs a program
that's very important
yeah but yes we have these debate right
now in Canada about the state and posing
some some values that I think that's not
the role of government yeah
is it actually part of the policy of the
Trudeau government that you if you're
pro-life that you actually can't be you
know in the party platform it's a party
platform yeah if you're a pro-life
person you cannot be a candidate for the
Liberal Party of Canada
I'm just saying Trudeau said that but
you know that government is all obsessed
by sex and gender last budget you know
that was a gendered budget what does
that even mean I mean they didn't have a
lot of economic data in the budget I'm
supposed to be a budget supposed to have
economy economic data you can add a lot
of economic data but I think the word
gender was in the budget three hundred
times so and and the fr will give you an
example if you want to build a pipeline
in Canada with the new bill c69 you need
to do intersect oriole sex and gender
analysis don't ask me what that means
intersection sexual sectional sex and
gender analysis that's in the
legislation so the sex and gender build
the pipeline to build a pipe oh yeah a
lot of people we're talking about this
when we were in Alberta yeah yeah the
sex and gender expert will look at the
impact of building a pipeline in a rural
community witness
woman and the sex and so it's crazy it's
an onsen it's crazy so and this
government is obsessed about that and I
think that's why people are looking for
an alternative so so a guy like Trudeau
it's hard to judge what's really going
on in someone's mind but do you think he
really believes in the things that he's
saying when it comes to all of this
gender stuff or is it just that it
always leads to bigger government and
what he wants fundamentally is bigger
government because he wants more power
he believed in state power yeah so so
that it's almost like it's a it's an
ends the ends justify the means it's
like you'll just say anything about
gender and all these things I think he
probably kind of believes them but at
the end they just give him more power I
think first of all he believed it and I
think also it's because he believed in a
big government that will fix every
problem in our society
that's his philosophy and you know when
he said that you know I don't know
Canada is no core identity or Canada is
the first opposed national state you
know people the understanding Canada
that we we are a nation we are not a
post nation-state we are we have
Canadian values and we share the Western
civilization values so for him is a
little bit like his father you know the
UN and the world it's important and mass
immigration and open borders and
everybody everybody can come to Canada
that's what people they don't like that
in Canada they want us to respect our
immigration system and and having a
sustainable immigration system so
Trudeau adding wants to build a big
government and at the end believe in a
supranational government you know he
just sang in 2010 with the UN there's
the UN UN PA UN Parliamentary Assembly
it's a it's group that we want to
promote a world government like the
the eu-parliament that will be able to
write legislation that will be biding
with and with countries and they will
lost their sovereignty and to do in 2010
promote that and believe in that so it's
all about the UN it's all about the big
government and it's all about him trying
to find the right policies that will
solve every problems but that's not the
case
just less regulation more freedom you
have more prosperity I think people are
tired of that in Canada
it almost rikes me as it's like a
psychological condition more than
anything else it's just like sort of
what like it's obvious to me that you
believe in just that the individual can
yeah to the best of their ability solve
their problems not all of them but to
the best very honestly and I think that
this other set of people believe that I
don't know it I would view it as almost
a very dim way of viewing humans that if
we all weren't controlled that endless
evil would spread everywhere I think
they believe that Canadians are children
and you know they must follow regulation
and but I trust you know I have faith in
people I think that they have the
ability the dignity and the right to
make their own decision and determine
their own destiny that's important for
us that's important for me and yes you
can make it can make a mistake but
you'll be responsible of your success
and your your your mistake that's how
you learn in a society that's why you
know speaking about that people like me
a little bit and they are looking at
Jordan Peterson and they single Bernie a
personal responsibiiity and in Jordan
also is its book it's all about that you
know clean your your high your room
before before cleaning the world so so
be responsible of your action and that's
what we want to do and that's what as a
politician I want to I want to do well I
mentioned it before we sat down but I
may as well say it on camera that when I
go to these events and with Jordan and
especially in the 12 or 15 we did in
Canada I say something about Trudeau and
the whole audience boos I say talking
about you and the whole crazy so so if
something good is half
you've mentioned borders a couple of
times yes this does seem to now be the
hot one at least in the United States
where we seem to be caught between
either a wall or open borders and it's
such an it's it's not a real choice I
don't think it's not a sensible choice
and in one hand if you're for the wall
they say you're racist if you say you're
for open borders then you're an
anarchist or whatever it is so what
would be the right way to look at
borders if you want to maintain your
national sovereignty yeah and that's a
debate that we're having right now in
Canada because as you know we have
people who are crossing the border from
the state of New York to Quebec and they
are asking to they said that they're
refugees and actually they are not real
refugees you know your life is not in
danger in the state of New York but that
being said they think yeah but but the
last two years I think more than 40,000
people cross the border illegally so the
Trudeau government doesn't want to fix
that and that's a big issue in Canada so
what I'm asking as a politician we have
an immigration system and that is it but
it was going very well at point systems
so it's a privilege to be Canadians and
we want people who come here to share
our Canadian values or basic Western
civilization values and and it's a
privilege so we have three kind of
immigrants in Canada the reunification
of family the refugees and the economic
immigrant the person that will come
because they have a job because the
business was not able to find the
Canadians for that job so they are
coming they have a job and usually it's
easier 20 greater society if you have a
job but we don't need to build a wall
between Canada and us we just need to be
sure to respect our immigration system
and the way to do that is to have a
discussion with President Trump about
the third safe country agreement we are
a we have an agreement with us about
that and to fix that loophole so people
who are crossing at a real point of
entry it's okay but people who are
crossing and
a real point of entry we they must go
back to the US and we must have an
agreement with the US about that and I
think we can have that kind of argument
if we sit with the Trump administration
but at the same time we must be clear
that people who are coming to Canada
must come from the right reason and
these people who are crossing our border
right now 40% of them will have to be
deport because they're not real refugees
so it's a big cost for Canadian
taxpayers because these people will be
deported maybe in three years from now
so we must fix that and we have a strong
position in our platform
yes we'll fix that at the border but we
need don't need to impose a wall we
don't need to create a wall but the most
important we need to focus on more
economic immigrants that's what we need
in Canada and a little bit less of
refugees and a little bit less of
reunification of family so that's a
strong position but seeing that yes it's
a risk in Canada well you can see that
as a politician but I'm taking that risk
and yeah what do you make of the
libertarian argument that is Pro open
border because I've had many guests here
that are libertarian that take that
position I've never been convinced of it
I actually I just I don't understand the
fundamental premise because as you said
earlier it's if you're a nation a nation
has borders that's just otherwise
everything is just in Amorphis blob but
what I'm sure you hear this with your
attorney in circles so what do you make
of that argument
yeah that's not coming from the left
that's coming for ended you know yeah
absolutely so our party is were not ante
immigration and were not open borders
and for mass immigration so what we want
it's a little bit less immigrant 250,000
a year like we had on the Stephen up or
not 350,000 a year to do increase in to
do a government the increase that by 40
percent so what I'm saying
when people say oh you know open border
is good it's not it's not everybody that
can be part of a nation if you don't
support all values
if you are I don't know pro Sharia law
that's against our values that's again
freedom between men and women equality
between men and women the respect of the
rule of law if you want to impose a new
rule of law Sharia law the integration
won't be very well in our society so
these people must the demo share our
values our Western civilization values
so that's why if you have an open border
and you want everybody from everywhere
to come to Canada that will create
tension and and dislike in the
population and that's happening actually
in Europe actually right now are you
able to point to that that's the one
thing that I've never understood that
Europe is having all of these
integration problems Merkel has
basically said she screwed up yeah you
know after letting a million people in
yeah are you able to point to that and
say you see they might have that's the
warning I'm doing that you know Jonas
Anthony are telling me Maxime a nothing
happen in Canada it's a great country I
said yes it is a great country but I
want this country to be like that in 20
years for now so that's why we must have
the discussion right now and people who
are coming to Canada much more share our
values if not you know they're not
welcome because the integration will be
very difficult and that's that's the
Trudeau government policy on extreme
ritika tourism so you know for Twitter
diversity is our strength strength and
for me it's unity who is our strength as
a country but to do is always pushing
for more diversity more diversity more
diversity and I said that and I tweet
about that more diversity won't help our
country at the end it will destroy our
country I know that we just Canada is a
diverse country with people coming from
different countries and with different
culture but at the end the integrated or
Society because they believe in our
freedom in our values in a and they want
to share our traditions and our heritage
celebrate our heritage so that's what we
want and we need to have that discussion
in Canada
and I think that discussion actually so
that's why I don't believe in open
borders I think it will create too much
diversity and I want people who come in
our country to share our values and it's
a privilege to be Canadians and like
it's a privilege to be an Americans we
must choose our immigrants and we did
that for the last 25 years and that was
very successful for our country and
people and it's interesting you're only
trying to roll it back to what it was 40
percent less I mean it's not like you're
doing something it's not like you're
saying we're not letting anyone know 100
people are coming back you know it's
years ago yeah and it is Justin Trudeau
is radical because the last poll in
Canada 49 percent of Canadians said that
they want fewer immigrants and only 6
percent 6 percent of Canadians said that
they want more immigrants so who is the
radical next in Bernie or Justin Trudeau
Justin Trudeau increase that by 40
percent so that's a fact and and that's
what Canada I think they are fed up with
it's extremely extreme reticular ism the
cult of diversity you know too much is
too much and I think Canadian can see
that in the future if you go on on on
that road will have more problem and the
integration would be more difficult and
but under 10 team immigrants and people
came in our country and they build this
country
so but they came for the right reason
and they're proud to be Canadians yeah
but they're liberals and and the
conservative are doing identity politics
and they try to please every special
interest group but every special ethnic
groups also so you know and they call
that outreach but for me the policies
must be the same for every Canadians and
we don't do any difference with your
race your gender or what so for us it is
not important but the Canadian
government is playing like explain that
that
they're doing these policies and I think
that won't that won't be good at the end
for our country yeah
so speaking of these policies I've also
seen you on Twitter you're not a big fan
of what's going on at the UN these days
no I'm not the least can you lay out why
the UN by why you're so down I mean it's
it's it's first of all it's a
dysfunctional organization just as
example I think the last two years
they've ordered 21 resolutions against
Israel on human rights and only one or
two resolutions again China or Cuba or
Venezuela so you know and the country is
that horror on that human right
committees like China all the bad guy
all the dictatorships so so it's it's a
joke but do you want want to impose
their vision of the world on other
countries and you know I was against
recently against the Compaq on migration
and they want migrants to be normal it
is not normal people must be able to
live in their country we must try to
bring peace and prosperity and that's
that's the most important but no they
want that to be normal there there's 250
million people that are migrants on the
globe and they want to facilitate that
so and the Trudeau government sign that
agreement but it was they were saying oh
it's not binding it's not binding but at
the end why is signing an agreement and
if you said that you will follow all
that but yeah it's not binding but you
will put legislation in place to be in
line with the agreement that you signed
so that will have an effect on our
country at the end it won't be imposed
by the UN it will be imposed by a
legitimate elected Canadian government
so this is ironic because the Paris
Accord was not by
- yeah and he was all about the power
absolutely yeah yeah you're right so I
think people there and I think I was
very clear about it and I had a lot of
support about that that migrant compact
and people understand that you know we
have or sovereignty as a country and we
must be able to select our immigrants
and so that's coming from the UN so yes
you're right I don't like the UN I think
that they're not so efficient and and
I'm clear about that yeah do you guys
have a strain you know we're seeing in
Europe now where there's nationalist
parties that there does seem to be a
strain of sort of ethno-nationalism or
something that has a different racial
kind of connotation to it do you guys
have a strain of that in Canada because
it seems to me that I think what's
happening and we're starting to see it
here is that if if the good liberals and
and the good libertarians and the people
who just want to live and let live if
they don't start making some advances
against this radical effort ISM that's
moving there's gonna be a lot of people
that break in a bad way yeah and in a
weird way I wouldn't be able to blame
them yeah and I say that is someone that
has no racism in my yeah yeah but they
would be left with no alternative as
they watch their country yeah crumble do
you have any of that no we don't and
it's a good news but at the end that's
why we must have this discussion yeah
and and I don't fear to have the
discussion for me there's no political
correctness
there's no taboo subject and we need to
have the discussion and then having that
discussion with Canadians and I think it
is time to have the discussion if we
wait too long that can happen in your
country yeah so so right now
I would imagine there's probably some
people on the right that are saying well
Bernie yeah if he gains too much
strength it'll sort of split the right I
mean this is always the argument against
libertarian yeah yeah and I say this is
someone that I voted for Garry Johnson
and you know and I get it is the more at
some micro level when third parties
usually the libertarian party that's
usually
gonna take from the Conservatives more
than the lefties and then then there is
an argument then you're always going to
end up with a lefty government I suspect
as the guy leading this thing you don't
buy that argument
I don't know long term I don't buy that
but actually it is the only argument
that my opponent the Conservative Party
of Canada has this guy you're gonna
fracture us that they have a weak leader
there's no conviction there you know the
conservative are doing a lot of polling
polling and focus group and survey but
they are not doing politics by
conviction and I'm doing politics by
conviction and we must speak about what
we believe openly with passion and
conviction and that's what I'm doing
that's a big difference with me and
Andrew Shearer and Andrew Shearer try to
please everybody and he said actually
the truth it was with the Toronto Sun
and he said my party is a centrist
centrist pragmatic political party open
for a lot of ideas for a lot of people
so what he's saying is he doesn't have
any principle doesn't have any
conviction doesn't have any vision for
the country
he wants to please everybody but at the
end when you please everybody you end up
pleasing nobody
so that's the conservative or not I
think I'm not happy with him but they
are telling me Maxine we want to win and
yes you are splitting the vote but I'm
saying in a democracy the vote it's
always played if you don't want anyone
to speak the vote it would be a dictator
you don't have so so what I'm telling
them is and Russia when I was with him
when I was a conservative he was not
winning against Justin Trudeau he was
always six to eight points behind Justin
Trudeau and maximum Bernie is not with
hand Russia right now and and Russia is
that winning is being in route behind
just need to do by four to six point now
so it's not able to win so what I'm
saying to people vote for your values
vote for what you believe in be part of
the change be with us we
have the momentum right now we have the
real conservative policies and ideas and
come with us
and we will see what will happen maybe
we can be we can have the balance of
power in in a parliamentary system we
can be in power off so I don't know I
don't know what will happen but I know
that we have the momentum and so you
think it's a risk will worth taking
regardless even if even if at the end of
the day the party splits or not the
money because it's two separate parties
but the votes are split enough that you
end up with Trudeau again you think it's
just long term it's what you have to do
that's it you have to vote what you
believe you know and I'm giving them
another alternative and you know why you
will vote for a politician that is
telling you something and at the any
won't do any reform you won't do
anything because it will look at the
poll and it won't be able to do that I'm
speaking about real conservative reform
before after and during an election time
every time so yes that there's a risk
over there that just needed to be
erected but maybe we'll have it would be
erect and only as a minority government
and if it's a minority government and we
are there with a lot of seeds we can be
the difference and we can impose our
reform to the government or we reverse
the government we don't know what we can
do but I don't know what can happen but
I'm telling them that's a risk but you
know vote vote for what you think will
be good for this country in the long
term that's what we're doing right now
we the they like the poll that's why I'm
telling you that's the only argument
that they have but the goal and I think
I can defeat Justin Trudeau the most
important from me actually it's to be
able to have candidates all across the
country in every writing and will be
able to have that so we're not a
regional party where our a national
party in Quebec and outside Quebec and
all across the country and also I would
be I will be present at the national
debate on on the national TV during the
during the election campaign in
september/october and that would be
important for me as the leader of a new
party to be the
and I think I'll be able to questions
the other leader to to challenge them
and that will help our party at the end
so we can be a big surprise and I'm
telling people come with us vote for
what you believe be part of the change
and and we'll be able to do something I
don't know what would be the end result
of all that but I can tell you that we
are able to change the country for the
better
yeah that that should be the ending but
I'm not quite done yet but that was that
was the ending portion here in a way
that was your that was your closing
stump speech there what do you make of
sort of the the state we haven't talked
at all about religion it's one of the
you know that we've talked a lot about
here and I know you're yes see familiar
Jordan Pederson Shepherd that it seems
that the way that Western countries have
say moved off of judeo-christian values
yeah that they've replaced everything
with a big state I actually don't know
what your oh yeah actually that's that's
I believe in that and then that happened
in Quebec in my own province in Quebec
at the plane show Louisville you know we
had the relationship with the state and
the church in Quebec in the 1950 1960 16
and and after that you know we we did at
the potential of all a quiet revolution
and so we were praised we replace the
the church by a bigger state and that
happened in Quebec and we still had a
big fat government at the plane solid
level in Quebec that's why you know
Quebec is a poor province in Canada we
have a kind of a formula in Canada in
the Constitution we call that the
equalization formula the rich provinces
are giving money to poor provinces and
Quebec received equalization money for
the last 50 years so so because bad
economic policies of the pension level
and because of a big state at the branch
level does it work there's no nothing
the money ever work and why did they
have to do it for 50 years if this was
so the good policy yeah yeah it's but
but it is unlike too
money and - but so what you're saying
about the rim when I think we did that
in Quebec and and at the federal level
with the total government they want a
bigger state absolutely so I agree with
Jordan when he said when he said that
that was the case at the branch level in
Quebec a little bit more evident but
also at the federal level so people want
politicians want a bigger government and
and the more bigger the government is
the more power they have the more
regulation they're doing the more
influence they will have and and so for
me I don't buy that so that so as a
libertarian in government which as I
started this is an odd thing because
it's the only type of people that want
to scale back the very thing they're
becoming part of yeah are you worried at
all that everything has become political
that it seems politics has sort of
replaced sports at least here in the
United States the way we talk about
politicians is the way you used to talk
about athletes when we worship these
people who've never accomplished
anything but they're good on sound bites
Trudeau has a nice hair and wears nice
socks if although you're clearly you're
doing all right in the sake but but that
we worship these people who should have
you know if we were doing this right
would have almost no control over us and
yet we we've elevated them to some
magical state that's got to be just
weird for you personally as someone that
you want to scale this thing yeah I can
yet you have to be part I have to be
part of that part of that to do that
yeah absolutely right but yes and I
think that the population sometime I
they're putting too much too much faith
in a politician to change things you
know and that's what I'm telling to
people you know I will I will put
forward the policies that would believe
in but after that you know one will have
more competition no more corporate
welfare a government that respect the
Constitution and and we'll all these
extreme military terrorism policies will
you know that's that it is there to buy
votes at ethnic vote and
with different communities will abolish
these policies so I'm telling them I'll
do that but at the same time I'm doing
that because I believe in you because I
don't want to save you for every
individual problems that you can have in
your life I want you to be responsible
that's a little bit but you know I'm the
only politician who speak like that
and for me you know I believe in free
markets I believe in competition but
when you don't have competition it is
fun in politics you know other
politicians are too afraid to say that
and for me that that's great because I
don't have political competition on what
I'm seeing but you're right you know
people must be responsible and we must
have a smaller government and I want I
want to have that job to be sure to do
what I want to do and I'll people in the
right way by giving them back their
their responsibility and giving them
back their own money and giving them
back they're increasing their purchasing
power so all the things that if they
have more money in their part in their
pockets their weeble they'll they'll be
able to do more things and so for them
or for their family so that's that's
what I want to do in politics and I like
that actually it's my best time in
politics right now yeah all right I
normally don't intend an interview
asking a favor my favor is this if you
can make this thing work in Canada can
you then send somebody down to fix the
Libertarians in the United States
because our libertarians need some help
I mean but your voice and someone that's
speaking clarity on libertarian issues
yeah because we have a lot of talkers
that are doing we have a lot of
youtubers and I think tanks that do it
really well but for whatever reason and
I again I voted for Gary Johnson I think
he's a really nice man but he wasn't a
great candidate
we need that what you're presenting so
if you've got anybody can you can you
send them our way when you're done with
this don't deal what was a pleasure
thank you so much for coming in and for
on maxime you can check out People's
Party of Canada CA
you
[Music]